welcome and Happy Thanksgiving although
it's the day after Thanksgiving it's
Black Friday so don't go shopping stay
at home and watch the H3 podcast am I
right that's right
or go shopping you got all day you're
off work anyway today we're here to
suffer for you
um and uh we're going to do it and and
tradition of Thanksgiving we're doing
our annual you laugh you lose each one
of us has curated five videos give or
take give or take I mean hopefully
follow the rules okay yeah who why give
or take who's give or take I don't know
if everybody has five I think I had six
so I had six as well at least five we
don't have five
I think we were having some problems
before the show but I think we're all at
five oh oh was it a copyright thing yeah
yeah yeah that's okay that's okay we
understand yeah we're in spot
responsible employees we understand that
by the way uh today's episode is
sponsored by a gamer sup let's go
absolutely love Yeah and remember if we
go
and yeah by the way if we get nauseous
and puke it had nothing to do with gamer
sub it's all the food that evil Sam has
cooked up for us yeah
so this is how the game works
Sam has prepared how many dishes there
are seven seven heinous
ungodly Abominations of uh and their
play on Thanksgiving dishes is that
right Sam that is correct in fact why
don't as I'm setting why don't you just
bring out the first dish and we can
Marvel at how gross it is all right and
how are you selecting is it random it's
random
how do you randomize it well there's one
that has to be last you randomized and
then you should pick it she picking that
well she knows what they are there's one
that's a dessert there's some they're
all side items there's not like a turkey
or anything okay it doesn't matter I
love saying random said what do you got
a hat you take a number out I mean how
randomly dealing she knows what they are
well she has an order that she's gonna
bring them out but she doesn't know what
order we're doing
please thank you well the first one's
from for my videos so each of us has
prepared
oh no I'm already a set of funny videos
are these the mashed potatoes
those look great I got no problem with
those
oh no not the not the grave yeah that
looks good that looks good actually but
I'm worried now I know it's not Sam was
like snickering about what a [ __ ]
monster she's been this year with these
foods do you have ndi Dan to show it oh
I do right here one second
let's take a peek oh good yeah yeah it
looks like honestly like a good classic
mashed potato nothing wrong with that
right Sam I think they all look good
fashion gravy so lastly the potato was
infused with uh peppermint but it was a
lot like a lot
it genuinely there were a lot of bad
things last year but that peppermint
potato that was the one that stuck with
me too yeah that was the worst one for
some reason it doesn't sound that bad I
know you should be getting it now Ian
there we are and so Sam um are you going
to explain what we've got here on the on
the table for us
should you taste it first or should I
say maybe don't don't reveal it until
after okay okay I think everyone should
try and guess whoever let's try this I
don't know what's worse like not knowing
what's up
I don't want to know I don't think this
one's that bad yeah I don't want to know
I don't know you'll see I do want to say
I've never seen a be distressed and
Olivia I'm so my legs are going crazy
I'm not good with this stuff like when I
I'm like I don't know I get like nasty
food I get weird about even sauce like I
get I don't like Ranch so you I mean
yeah I joined them I don't even like
looking at it like if I'm eating like I
kind of like will turn my head if
someone next to me has a bunch of sauce
yeah well you do puke readily you are
the show's yeah resident puker so you
got your bucket you're ready to go and
Olivia as is tradition you have a puke
phobia of sometimes but you're sitting
across it is a tradition for me to be
scared of the bomb yeah there's a good
chance Amy's gonna puke here today for
sure yeah that'll be nice that'll be fun
that'll be a nice Thanksgiving Day
anything for the show
yeah so I'm going to present I'm going
to go first I'm going to present my
videos one by one for all five of them
and if any of you guys laugh you gotta
take a bite of what looks like otherwise
delicious bowl of traditional mashed
potatoes and gravy it looks like a
really good version of it too
until you taste it
yeah so so I guess with that all being
said I guess let's just get right into
it what do you guys think okay
yeah and by the way oh I forgot to
explain yeah everyone was super mad
about at us for skipping out on Gabe's
birthday party
and I do want to say that we didn't
Escape
scot-free we realized there is the white
cloud game birthday curse that is
affecting us all differently uh Cameron
is out with food poisoning he brought
out the biggest gnarliest torta I've
ever seen in my life after the show
yesterday where did he bring it from I
don't know it doesn't he doesn't even
know he found it he's at some place he
literally said we were like where did
you even get that from he said I don't
know I've never seen a sandwich like it
like I was looking up massive torta
images on Google and I couldn't even
yeah find one that compared to the next
level he was gifted it wait he was
gifted
it was something like the best thing I
could find it was like maybe like this
but honestly it was bad yeah yeah
exaggerating double that it was I never
say anything like it the story is so
weird like what yeah give it to him he
must have known did he got it from a
restaurant but he didn't know he didn't
know what the restaurant was called and
then we're like well where was it and he
was like I don't know I don't know and
that's the item that he chose so well he
busted it out of the fridge and we're
like yo what the hell is that bro but it
looked kind of good I'm not gonna like
I'm not even gonna judge you but but but
at the same time last night he's like
I'm puking I'm so sick I got I'm so
messed up from that tore up at the same
Dan did the surprise Pikachu okay I
can't say that I was terribly surprised
by it either he said he was puking all
night yeah he's he's very sick rip to
The Goat in fact two yeah well and then
so Zach thank you uh is very sick still
and I think that's part of the Gabe
curse he's got the blue
and a b you've got a little bit of the
cave birthday curse yeah my computer my
new computer that me and Dan just
recently built the cooler and it just
kind of stopped working and I found out
that that I guess that's it's not
uncommon with that but also my PS5 just
randomly froze and wouldn't turn back on
oh my God yeah all your electronics a
boss and got a war of hard ass boss I
was pissed I was pissed that's probably
further than me and your hair falling
out and my hair yeah what was that about
you're losing your hair that's because
right here like three times yeah like
they were doing it there's one spot that
would not bleach no matter what I did it
was like impenetrable and uh now it's
just falling out
and now everybody know who jealous is I
told her about it and she was like he's
doing it himself no I tried to stop him
I threw away all my bleach stuff I
promised Lena because she has to sit
there hearing me like scream is like
yeah listen to your head yeah yeah well
it's gay it's gay but he got you yeah
and um I actually did the members only
live stream and I had to ship my brains
out if I mean I don't know if that's the
Gabe curse but I'll write it off I
thought something was happening because
we were like setting up and then we
turned back on the stream and you were
in the seat you were just gone no it
wasn't good
yeah anyone else I think my laptop is
dying that's a gay person oh interesting
nothing's happened to me yet I don't
know if I will be affected by the curse
though because I unlike everyone else
didn't say that I would go he's coming
for you bro
damn this episode what game final
destination birthday curse Olivia I
don't know if I think you you yeah you
didn't RSVP did you or did you I said I
would go if if someone else sorry your
cursed I have to get gas on the way home
we all wanted to go we genuinely had a
lot of fun there's an empty tank
everybody just happened to had something
right yeah it was it was a weird
series of events but yeah we're gonna
talk about it on tomorrow yeah we don't
need to get into it but at my long way
of explaining that cam
and Zach are gone at a commission and so
this is what's left dude for sure Zach I
think
he's fine he just didn't want to do it
right really that thought crossed my
mind
but he had to have planned a haircut
yesterday too next time we gotta send
somebody to do a home check right well
okay by the way
about an hour ago a photo of them with
Cam and it looked like an airport and I
literally I turned to Sam and I was like
came at the airport what no no no no
okay but I have a suspicion about cam
too because all yesterday for unprompted
and for no reason he's like yo I can sit
it out if we don't have enough seats and
I was like why are you even saying that
way
and he kept saying that kept saying it I
was like no we want you in the show he's
like I can skip it from vmrc so I was
like imagine if it was a huge plan he
showed up with a big torta know
because that story is very suspicious
yeah the fact that he didn't know well
and the fact that he like liked that he
didn't know too
yeah and he brought it out he's like
look everybody at my daughter yeah he's
totally this is gonna make me sick or
anything yeah whoa I don't know where I
got it
all right but anyway let's get started
uh we hope we wish them well and uh well
I'll wish that I called in sick after
this episode too all right so I'm gonna
go first
I feeling pretty good I spent a lot of
time on this in fact I'll even go a step
further I created an original
um
old friend old fans will know I used to
do these exe video edits and so I made
one okay put some effort in and I'm
coming for Dan specifically with that
saying that yeah but I'll open that one
last so let's start with Dan exe is it
so let's just start from the top here's
one that's just a little something to
warm you guys up
so you laugh you lose guys and we're all
Watching Sam and Ian are gonna be the
judges here today right so they're
watching and just for the record smiling
is not a laugh but any kind of chortle
or exhale or grunt any kind of you're
out right okay okay should we lose we
have to take a bite and swallow or
swallow okay okay
I mean I know you're you're like you you
have if you could eat that chip okay
that's true um just so we're clear the
amount of times we laugh matters right
yes so the rules are at the end
people may have caught that there's
seven dishes but there's only six of us
there's an ultimate dish whoever laughs
the most oh my God we'll have to eat the
grand finale holy [ __ ] okay so that is
there's a lot of motivation your
motivation yeah Do Not Laugh dude I
laugh when I'm nervous I'm already left
together bro okay
dad's worried about you all right here
we go everybody what eyes on the screen
eyes on the screen eyes on this goddamn
screen all right here we go
no sound no sound
dude I got you so good already
that is so funny I was almost laughing
before anything happened one more time
because y'all are trying to be okay
right and let's say
one replay only okay that's because in
the past that's fair that's fair you
have run the videos into the ground yeah
I just I saw this one and I just I was
like that's the replay count because you
guys made it through the first yeah no
no no no
you're about to crack bro staring me
down just stare at this [ __ ] guy bro
he's minding his own goddamn business
yeah and what's funny kind of is that
he's like fine you know I thought he was
[Laughter]
all right just Stila that's okay I'm not
gonna push it I'm not gonna push it all
right go ahead and tell us what you
think I don't think you have to worry I
think I'm the loser of this game no it's
so hard for me not to I might start to
feel more motivated after a few bites
maybe yeah and you just need to take a
bike you don't have to eat a little
nibble to just get the taste all right
so it's like a neighborhood like a tiny
neighbor that's more than it right
that's it Sam knows so trust me I've
eaten it will be okay describe what
you're going through she doesn't seem
too affected she likes it oh it's okay
what the hell that one's not that bad
there's just it's a bad combination
there's some stuff in it like spices
what is it it's it's Cameron is there
wrong maybe we should wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay raw chicken you
were gonna say yeah I'm just kidding
all right okay okay all right Ela and
you're keeping score back there right
Ian yes okay so that's one point okay
now all right okay okay all right I
thought that one was pretty strong but
uh you guys are Fierce competitors I
think it's probably tough to be first
too I'm working very hard right now to
not laugh me too yeah apparently this
one's not even gross either so there's
not a lot of pressure uh Olivia make
sure you're uh scooted close to Dan in
frame oh so quick yeah all right guys
here's number two please enjoy
everybody's eyes on the screen hold on
this one needs audio
we have audio should be
okay
Lena I are you Charlie over there
let me play it again for you Dan because
it's a good one he he tried he tries so
hard to Wrangle it yep and and and you
know it's just not happening for him and
that I like how his daughter goes really
like idiot dumb you suck dude
I think I may have
I may have screwed over lean on that one
because I made her laugh right before
the mashed potatoes I said Cameron's in
there we actually Elena's a giggler
though she's gonna make it tougher for
all of us because it's kind of
infectious you know you know listen I
heard you twirling I was gonna call you
out I'm glad you just went for it I
think just because you picked that video
made it funnier to me
yeah interesting I like that I did enjoy
that I did love the really yeah it's a
big factor I just I liked how he was
like just so lazily eight [ __ ] over
there very slow yeah I always laugh when
people get hurt
that's why I got that weakness too
that's right this is okay right that's
fine yeah very good you're just gonna do
it you're good it's really not that bad
you describe it
look it has like a spice to it yeah you
mean spiced like spicy or like spices
it's a little spicy and there's chunks
of something garlic it's very garlicky
just like a garlic Bonanza see I like
garlic I like garlic yeah it's not that
bad garlic maybe I should just laugh can
I have something
you can try it you guys hungry I guess
we're warming up okay yeah it's
definitely a warm up it makes sense yeah
I thought they were random
all right so this one's a two-parter
it's very short it's a series it's two
very short videos it's I put them as the
same category okay but you have five
total this counts as one okay and this
counts as one so this one is a old
standby
such an iconic video it always gets me
yeah this looks familiar and um well
just just enjoy everybody watching okay
here we go Alina you mentioned that you
like to see people get hurt so I think
this one in particular oh wait don't
make us laugh right before who says I
can't who says I can't part of the
strategy yeah
yeah no I just I heard the navigating is
totally valid yeah come on Ela it's like
how with um he's not here this year but
Zach oftentimes in the past got me
because his videos were like they
weren't even funny but it was the fact
that Zack found it funny made it really
[ __ ] funny to me yeah yeah so just
keep your eye on this woman who's about
to die basically and now she's fine I
think she's fine she's fine yeah yeah in
Minecraft yeah in Minecraft she's gonna
be all right she's totally fine
oh my God could this be any smaller well
you said it's an old video I won't put
that on you Elena okay here we go but no
now you're in trouble if you left
yeah so so you know the trapdoor and uh
you know people keep stuff down there
and well
I always found them a little bit uh
hazardous
is that good she just disappeared bro
she's like there one minute and then
she's gone the next
I don't know if Dad's laughing right now
I mean
the ruling is he is in the clear okay
okay thank you yeah but these these trap
doors always freak me out like we're
walking around when we lived in New York
I just found them I was like what the
[ __ ] these things are so dangerous and
it's right behind the cashier stand and
it's like you know she doesn't look like
a person who's gonna take a fall very
gracefully to begin with you know
and so the two I think you laughed Dan
oh you all three left
that's a hilarious thing to say well
well it's true I mean for Christ's sake
you know what I mean give her a warning
look at this I'm gonna be honest I
thought I thought that was gonna happen
to Linda
oh yeah because she kept walking by the
stairs at the Ghost Hunt I thought Linda
I said you're about to be on spirit all
I did is born yo but like look look she
just she just disappeared back
yeah no you're good yeah yeah you're
good but I have to take this thing yeah
all of you girls who laughed are are
fine but Olivia uh just took a bite what
do you think
oh she does not agree oh garlicky yeah
like maybe chunks of garlic I'm kind of
into that I wonder if I'll like it no
but I'm not gonna try it I'm Gonna Save
myself yeah so um this is kind of part
two of uh the continuation of the same
uh uh Novella if you will it's a live
leak video huh yeah after a great start
well and so basically we're having the
same kind of situation here you got the
trap door
in the middle of the [ __ ] shop I mean
you know what I mean and um well there
you go
the fact that it closed after him and
hold on let me just break this down
because everybody
everybody's last but Amy so let me just
break this down for a little bit maybe
first of all you gotta grab you couldn't
try to grab the trash can to save him
okay so you gotta first of all he's dead
that's not gonna help him and second of
all the best part yo is that the store
earners they just close it and say well
yeah well we'll tell about later [ __ ] it
we'll get we'll move the body later look
at this [ __ ] what let's close the truck
like all right move the body you know
how to make me break is Lena laughing so
much
you're gonna make me break all right I'm
going for these girls
I really do not so nervous I do not like
garlic
Dan is did it a good job everybody else
in there there's something other than
garlic for sure yeah Ginger is it Ginger
maybe it is oh see this is kind of
innovative
this is almost like an Innovative maybe
a Michelin star mashed potato I feel
like it is if you have if you have the
the
ginger and garlic is there garlic in
there too there's do you want me to tell
you what's in it or wait okay okay by
the way is the gravy Shenanigans no okay
so the gravy is that's a real stuff I
thought that gravy was for sure gonna be
gnarly when you poured it on okay you're
going easy on us so that's the trapdoor
Saga thank God everybody but my my
Magnus Opus Is Yet To Come okay right
uh this one is you know a video that and
again you like seeing people get hurt
you know what I like seeing better than
people get hurt old people get hurt oh
no and so basically we just lost like 20
Trump voters and that's good that's a
dub
you guys are why are you guys laughing
because I imagine just a bunch of old
people laugh whatever you want what's
going on
wait you guys are they're already
laughing you haven't started the video
Don't say that what did we lost 20 Trump
quarters nobody died nobody died yeah
it's a joke oh my God I thought jokes
were now legal only on Twitter bruh I'm
just gonna say like statistically
speaking the majority of them are going
to be Trump voters and uh we need to
change the voter base if it's by seesaw
then let it be out here it is
now if I'm at 90 I'm not necessarily
thinking
let's hobble on to a giant seesaw but
they do it
and uh you know good thing they're agile
right baby oh my God the one at the end
has a cane they're all they're all good
crappy bro here it goes
this is it
it's a Stairway to Heaven my dude good
job
nobody huh that's good [ __ ] though that
was good and you're joking
yeah yeah so uh you know what happens
when you get a bunch of old dudes on
you know the only thing that make this
better is if there's just a ditch here
trap door this doesn't dirt on it you
know yeah trap door an earth door that's
it dude this is you know what I mean
let's just streamline the whole death
yeah
definitely got fatally
the sound really goes
oh my God
oh [ __ ] nobody huh okay
just me
okay
good videos
I'll give you guys the pass because it's
my first playthrough but if you watch
closely on the right here like this
whole like they put like the most frag
yeah
everything about this
dude just a really bad idea but watch
the watch these guys get really [ __ ]
up on the end here watch this it's a
huge fall
people could not fall like that they
can't oh my God and like people with
canes like
so funny man it's so good so there's
that one and I'm glad everyone enjoyed
that yeah
wow loves liked it yeah it's so funny
because they're like trustful and
they're not doing anything to slow down
they can't they're old as [ __ ] they can
barely walk like what do you do
thank you
you know what they thought as they were
falling it's happening
I heard them all right so here's one
more old man uh one it's fun it's
exciting all right it's a little
unexpected and we love that we love our
old people though we we kid the old
folks don't we okay guys please
everybody eyes on television and here it
is
[Laughter]
oh it's so good
Jesus
one more time one more time one more
time yes he just hit he didn't take the
curb laughs
all right Dan I got you pretty good and
you're in trouble take a play and then
in the meantime the next one is the one
that I really worked for so okay I'm so
nervous about this yeah I don't know if
I over edited it or
Dan's not loving that second bite
I mean it's just everything's turned up
ten times too high like the flavor
combination isn't bad but it's just way
too much
um
so this is the one I worked on and I
hope it's funny and not just like kind
of weird but let's see you might
recognize it though
um
actually it's not how did this not get
claimed because I edited it like a [ __ ]
it's my Rembrandt bro it's a new video
now it's an original yeah the faces
already I thought to do that because
this is look at this idiot
that's a lot I've never heard Dan laugh
more than watching this video all right
you guys ready so this is this is the
one that I really uh invested in so here
we go maybe watch the films
eyes up yeah eyes up
Dan's already laughing
he's gonna enjoy
[Music]
my favorite part like this
hmm
I was enjoying that okay
oh God good funny I held my breath there
did you not laugh no I didn't [ __ ] you
just Dan oh that was great dancing uh
yeah that whole side of the table
that second cut to the to the driver
dude he was so funny he was like that
man was scared for his life wow yeah
yeah
everybody's worse
was not that bad so yeah Sam unveiled
the uh the actual recipe please
that is mashed potatoes with ginger
paste it's a whole bottle of gender
paste
18 garlic cloves oh my God
it has almost a whole thing of garlic
powder in it holy [ __ ] dude that's what
it is so it's right so so cut all of
that by like until like on the 20th yeah
I like all that those ingredients
there's like garlic seeds the first bite
is better they get worse and like oh man
see I'm already feeling nauseous though
this is gonna be a bad it's not it's
really not bad Ginger is good for nausea
that's true actually you know what
the ginger I don't like the mashed
potatoes I'm not in general yeah but
yeah I think uh not great Sam had
designed this as like an A B uh I know I
know she did because I hate garlic
here he was like Oh I thought you were
gonna [ __ ] me over with garlic because I
hate garlic cheese
[Music]
well he was highly motivated I've been
listening to you all all of you I've
been listening
oh no oh it's our ad reader 30 minutes
ready minutes already okay so um
obviously my turn is done so I'm gonna
pass off the reins after this uh gamer
sup moment but uh what's our scoreboard
right now uh Ian for the first round uh
Lena has two uh a B has zero
uh Ela has three Dan has three and
Olivia has two oh my goodness all right
I think I did good I'm proud
yes last year you you brought some some
Boomer moments it wasn't good sure and
uh you definitely stepped it up big time
thank you man I I put a lot of work a
lot of the time yeah yeah the whole
evening he was I wanted to do it
I came down stairs after the boys were
asleep I thought it was down like long
time ago and he was like I only have one
link so far oh my God what I had two I
had that too but but um I want to
re-watch that Ila did that [ __ ] in like
10 minutes bro oh wow I kind of
struggled it took me a while I wish I
had thought to make an edit of that Jay
Leno because that like they said I mean
we've watched that we actually mentioned
it the other day because he's now had
another accident I guess to be clear to
everybody
that is not the accident that caused his
current injury he was this was a while
ago he surprisingly was completely fine
I was thinking even from the current one
I heard that he said that he'll be fine
and awake yeah he's fine I was thinking
of throwing in some pictures of burn
victims and [ __ ] but that would have
been maybe two maybe a little bit maybe
his Wikipedia photos I don't know but I
didn't I think I kept it clean I kept it
good for you thank you we could put that
up on the highlights or something you
know it's a little effort I did okay
thank you uh quickly to our favorites
sponsor sup Nation gamer Subs Gamers
rise up yes check out actually gamer
stops having a Black Friday sale right
now they're giving out free white wafu
cups with orders of fifty dollars while
supplies last
[Music]
Cherry Baby
they just released a new limited edition
waifu hoodie that is so warm and comfy
which matches that new waifu cup
they haven't got a beanie to keep you
warm in the winter too available now use
the code history I got ice in my mouth
feeling
use code H3 and you will get 10 off your
whole order and that's always going to
be true oh the link in description takes
you right to the website and auto
applies the discount gamer Subs are
healthy and more affordable alternative
to energy drinks or soda if you're
drinking sugar you're taking a fat
[ __ ] L dude it's just not the way
gamer stuff is the way it helps you stay
focused
without a crash or regret they also have
caffeine free options available if you
just want a great tasting drink without
sugar
uh with no caffeine
I like the caffeine though it gets me
charged up man I love this gamer stuff
boy
um
stop drinking sugar high sugar diets
have been associated with an increased
risk of many diseases including heart
disease the number one cause of death of
Gamers no I'm just kidding that'd be
funny though we're worried about you
Gamers normal cause of deaths worldwide
gamer subs don't use sugar rather than
running to the store and cracking a can
of some sugary crap you can enjoy gamer
Subs by simply throwing Two Scoops into
a Shaker or water bottle and that's it
yeah a lot of people actually find that
uh gamer sup is a gateway to a healthier
lifestyle
um but I love gamer stuff and I hope you
all will enjoy with code H3 what do we
got here this this is info about their
Black Friday sale indeed way through cup
oh it's a new season season 3 12. season
three of gamer Subs limited edition
waifu hoodie limited edition waifu cup
mouse pad do they got the 3D titties
doesn't look like it
no only 2D titties and they got even uh
uh a pack of cards so there it is gamer
stuff we love you guys Happy
Thanksgiving we love gamer soap and
thank you guys for supporting our
sponsor
and with that being said who's next here
we are ela's gonna be going Sam you want
to bring up the next dish to get us all
excited motivate us
so okay this looks like a play on the
traditional
um uh yams with with the marshmallows on
top that couldn't be bad
you want to show it then that looks so
good how could that be bad that looks
fantastic it looks like legit I don't
know EMS are what are you so what's your
sweet potato oh Gila all right how are
you feeling you confident I mean you put
these together pretty fast because I put
it fast together because
um that's just my life you know I don't
have a lot of time for stuff
to be honest
I got a Time manage CEO and I gotta
still watch my shows yeah I feel that a
little fun for me you know I have to say
though when you came down and you were
already done with them all yeah I felt
like hers are gonna kill hers are gonna
slay I'm sure of it we shall see all
right well let's get it all right first
one
um let's just go come on dude don't [ __ ]
up
just like listen it can be anything as
long
as anything and so first thing I went to
in my mind two and a half two minutes
pain Jordan everything budding no
compilation okay all right
so ashamed of her breasts that she lets
a Machiavellian psychopath cut them off
you have no idea how many people that
this is My Kryptonite it's not fair
[Laughter]
you have no idea
fan and I'm moved by this especially I
mean don't forget those comments young
people especially young people with a
comments
I'm gonna get into this I'm gonna get it
there's nothing too much corruption and
power it's like how the hell do you
expect them to react how the hell well I
shouldn't do anything man you know no
man
yeah the most fundamental reality is
pain yes yes yeah is there anything more
fundamental than pain no
love
really so deep though oh my God I'm paid
love and truth
that's what you got I thought it was
love and happiness the song
yeah
they're more powerful than pain
maybe they're the most real things
let's try not to laugh exploration of
their Triumph the initial depth of their
despair oh he looks like a deep fake in
this one
and uh
so I wouldn't change that oh my God but
it's not nothing
it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
well I think it's I think oh my God he
did an interview against God for the
crime of being I kind of laughed just
because of how absurd it is that's
really what I think oh my God it's Kane
the way he stops look at his hair just
look at his hair people's your guy hey
God
the field and beat him to death how do
you feel about that look at my
sacrifices went I didn't feel about that
rewarded
yeah it's like
yeah that's what it is at the bottom of
the hell of things the bottom the hell
of things
my tendency to feel a hell of a lot more
sorry for a set of confused isolated or
lonely pubescent girls who have no one
to love them enough
to I would love them appreciate who they
are
then I do for one over privileged and
unfortunately confused narcissistic
Hollywood star I would love their
budding breasts oh did I make it oh my
God
I'm Gonna Make You make you guys the
thing is the thing is no it was that was
good though I really trans broke several
times I really just tried to think like
I'm one of his disciples and I'm gonna
be moved by this you are the greatest
Minds like one of his students wouldn't
be laughing at that [ __ ] they'd be moved
to tears okay Dan what a gentleman did
you left there I don't
back
damn we Ian you're the judge you are the
judge well Dan said at one point I just
laughed I mean um here's the thing wait
you said it wasn't a genuine thing it
was more of like oh what an [ __ ] kind
of like yeah it was when the what's his
name showed up and I was like yeah like
Ian you you you're the judge man yeah
exactly I don't know I mean I did
something up if I'll eat it if uh nah
you're getting the clear yeah I don't
think I can't it was not a laugh
that orange don't look right man yeah
it's like sweet potato
now make sure you get a good bite okay
it has layers does she need the
marshmallow marshmallow I feel like yeah
that's part of the experience that's a
good bite that's a that's a very good
one is that fine
Sam's given approval I'm going first
Stan
yeah go ahead I dished it up because I
wasn't sure but it sounds like I'm I I'm
in the clear it's just you know blind
solo yeah and if you could describe your
way through it
it's sweet okay
potato and marshmallow what the hell oh
really I think you need another bite oh
yeah there's something you missed it
sounds like maybe you should queue up a
bite for her Sam if that's because yeah
do you want to because this is fine so
far okay Elena's loving it she went back
for a second all we use lemonade she's
having the time for life
it kind of reminds me of baby food
yeah is that the problem you got to get
a little bit deeper into the middle
let's let the chef I'm sure there's
chunks of tuna in there some [ __ ] bites
already okay we take some of this home
actually
yeah leftovers
oh oh my God
so here okay there's a chunk of
something in there
what is that okay so what the [ __ ] is
that an olive Zach's
fingernails
great Stuffed Olive dust can't be a
decade okay I think it's stuffed I love
it yeah yeah no I see the hole okay
potatoes yeah right it's just an olive
well we don't I mean I'll reveal it but
I'm I'm shocked that's all you taste
because there's something in there that
is crazy all right let's wait hey I mean
listen nobody could say she didn't try
to leaning you know whole damn slice it
or not yeah there you go next stop just
a little I think Lena is just like the
Dark Horse of every competition she's
just an Unstoppable Warrior I'm weird
when it comes to food though no
everything you're like that it's weird
just say I'm weird when it comes I mean
but the the spicy chip in this it's like
two different extremes so you've got it
all covered a little Wheezy Lil Wayne
reacting to the goat left oh boy
um who's number one Jay Jay-Z um
that's cool it's okay that's right
number three that's okay I thought Drake
was gonna be number one aims don't even
own the list Eminem
who else was on the list
Gucci Mane or something listen Eminem
shout out my [ __ ] Gucci
shout out my [ __ ] Gucci
kind of a Class Act I like how he's like
I don't know why when I first watched it
I laughed out loud no I've seen that
clip
that um I agree too
now I like how he's that was classy he's
like yo Gucci man no this one is
classic I know we've watched it on show
it's like one of my older videos so okay
I thought I should included
[Music]
no we're in it cut it hey I'm Dina look
at my feet my feet are straight ahead
you don't want to do that you want to
turn your feet out I'm going to do this
backwards
and that's what makes it look like
hip-hop what this is this is the whitest
everything's down it's almost racist
absolutely the first thing that you need
to know about hip-hop
it's all about your posture
and you know growing up my posture was
really bad my mom used to tell me all
the time stand up straight stand up
straight well you know what I was
standing up straight and Hip Hop is this
one two three four hit ah and ah the
more relaxed you are that's what makes
you doing like a dosey doe with this the
first thing I will say to you you want
to do hip-hop you got to stand like this
in a hip-hop head we have this boom bam
every time
your hands are always like this I'd love
to get stuff I'm just hitting it I'd
love to get a little Wheezy to uh react
to this for sure
dude he's still happy to be there
straight I went to this club right and
um
they had no baggy pants and no sneakers
wow okay I didn't know what to think
familiar from an African piece
um and the African piece it was like
this Africa beef but in hip-hop it's
like this see there's a difference
[Music]
this is me this is how I am this is a
lifestyle
this is it I'm into points a lot
there's not your average points
people ask me all the time what are you
going to do when hip-hop goes out
hip-hop is an attitude it's right here
it's how you feel it's a style [ __ ] so
it can go out hit hit ah whoa Flex foot
back that
isn't how you dress is the way you look
I want to tell you another thing that
makes hip hop hip-hop
[Music]
[Applause]
I do this at the end of class every
class I hit here
and I hit here
hit here sometimes I vary it I'll give
him a
H they look at me like I'm crazy but
then they know this right here is me
and I'll give them the
peace I'm out I know one thing for sure
she has the M work though
that doesn't count no that video made me
no
hip hop is an attitude
I want to see like I want to see like a
bunch of my favorite rappers right to
that try not to laugh more hard okay I'm
doing good so far we gotta leave here to
see how Olivia's reaction is was it just
uh Olivia that time I guess yeah all I
know is a one meat get that Oliver it's
just Olivia I wonder what because that's
that video has to be from like the 90s
right I wonder what it looks like now
what she's up to these days she said
she'd never give it up she's still doing
it she's on Tick Tock but I like how she
was in a way she's like yeah I
acknowledge that hip-hop will die one
day she's like it's an attitude it
doesn't matter you'll live in my heart
yeah she killed it hip hop is an
attitude all right Olivia maybe maybe
there's more to this dish than what
meets that those marshmallows don't look
right Sam would you do those why are
they so gooey
okay is this fine I didn't do it that's
great marshmallows that has to be a good
bite
Olivia's having a different reaction oh
she's gagging gagging oh you're gagging
really
really no spit it out she just spit it
out okay
okay the way that the way that I
described that
he's like oh
a lot of mush and then you break through
it and then there's like another layer
of mush that you break through and then
there's like another is there more
inside the olive did you stop something
in there no there there is a pit or not
a pit but uh what is it a stuff yeah
yeah
yeah it was just what about the flavor
worse huh was it just sweet potato it
was very sweet and then it like hit me
with something really it was I mean the
olive was super acidic and gross but
there's something else
enough to Leo I wouldn't know Lena's
taking that home
you have any doggy bags uh Sam I don't
like it don't get me right I don't like
it but it's just not wasn't that bad for
me
um
I'm kidding he's not kidding my mom's a
bad cook too is she really I don't think
would she be pissed if she's if she saw
him say that she doesn't know he says
that so well she doesn't know
she loves me though I'm her favorite so
I left her today
um Ethan can you make everybody laugh
for a second so that they're in giggly
mode for me
um
okay
so
um the next one was supposed to be like
a two-parter but the first part got it
copyright claim whatever so we're done
to the second one
so
I guess it's probably better if I say so
I always loved the Matthew McConaughey
commercials
yeah the Lincoln yeah it's like a
compilation of his commercials this one
is an AI put together commercial okay
wow
love that for him
predictive text and Matthew McConaughey
impersonator
how are you going to move
I just stand there and look at you
move forward
that's it
sometimes that is taking care of
yourself
it's not about being anyone that's not
you
it's not about being cool it's about
respect and balance
1800 ghosts want to find you and take
you back
drive to The Sweet Spot
drive a Lincoln
that was so a robe an AI wrote the
script based on his that's not done oh
my God I didn't mean to be cool
I just like the chase
sometimes you gotta find that balance
where you can't go back
just forward
that's the right place
That's The Sweet Spot
a bull can Define whatever it may be
that's where the ghosts are that's the
place where I drive and Lincoln
oh my God the ghosts
you did the video's not done bro you're
out there laughing oh it's not I thought
it was over sorry there's more right
there and you're sitting there giggling
your head on I thought it was over yeah
I'm just saying everybody one more round
laughing willy-nilly out here all right
[Music]
I didn't mean to actually move forward
I just like the seat
that's a sweet spot
sometimes I want to just sit there and
reminisce or chase ghosts
you can respect that statement
going back to see where you came from
where you been you're almost there I
want to take the long way
oh it's so funny the moments they pick
up with the Chasing Ghosts in The Sweet
Spot it's so good all right um so I'm
just gonna avoid eating the marshmallow
part which apparently isn't the nasty
part anyways that's the Saving Grace
apparently right so maybe this actually
works so he's just taking sweet potatoes
that fine or do you need all of Sam
you need you need at least one Olive one
Olive
oh brother Lord help me Jesus I think
it's just stuffed with like you know
it's like a vodka of I don't think it's
weird [ __ ] instead
Dan is positive wait that was an
immediate wait this is not like what
Lena did yeah
wait what's happening then wow
oh my God
dude he took one bite into it it made me
gag oh my God what did you taste
how could these reactions be so
different how did you do that Lena what
I don't know I
so wait what did you taste because I
don't know what's going on in there
well I mean the all the olive just on
its own taste sorry I'm not talking to
the mic the olive combined with the
sweet potato is already nasty but I
think it's whatever it's stuffed with
and I yeah right I can't put my finger
on what that flavor the mush on top of
mush on top but you didn't okay as soon
as I bit into all of it there's just
something else in there that I don't
really think you can see so wow I can't
wait to find out what's going on I'm
curious dude you bailed fast on that one
dude again like it was bad immediately
but as soon as I bit down into that
Olive it just like squirted something
out and onto my tongue that just it was
immediate gag mode all right all right I
just have a last one
um
Dan you better be careful because you're
probably topping the list at this moment
I think you're not gonna be up there no
what's the score again
Dan has four and Ela Olivia and Lena all
have three
whoa all right
now
um when I had to think of where to find
weird funny videos I know Snoop Dogg
always posts like wow okay
so this is
it's a little too filled with the Holy
Spirit
his return and the closer we get to him
the faster things are going to happen
the faster the healings the faster the
Deliverance
[Applause]
I can't believe this whoa that was good
we're gonna watch it again yeah they're
getting closer to his return and the
closer we get to him the faster things
are going to happen the best of the
healings the faster the Deliverance
[Applause]
wow shout out that was good Dan was that
a laugh yeah come on it was over I don't
know he's playing fast and loose with
the Laughing Rose because it's over
nothing
judge
ah you were right on the line there Dan
that's what I'm saying he's playing fast
and loose with it I'm not I'm not biting
another olive I'll add more of the sweet
potato if you really want me to but it's
up to Ian and Sam I'm not I'm not I I'm
in no position you can have a little
sweet potato as a treat okay so yeah try
to get that down because I'm really
curious what the hell is in those sweet
potatoes
what you doing Olivia
tastes fine
I can tell that there's like some some
seepage from whatever I tasted before
into the sweet potatoes but the the
flavor of the sweet potato is strong
enough that it's tolerable It was again
Olive biting into the olive is when it
really all right so she needs to eat
another yes wait another how many have
you already eaten one
that's right but have you already had
one yeah it was the first one yeah
I'm not going to count that as a point
for Dan okay but that's definitely an
Olivia and a little bit of a penalty
just but not a point yes okay I like I
respect that
how about that so ugly dude I'm
perfectly fine not laughing once like
last year I talked to big game and I got
[ __ ] laughed way too much but I'm not
doing this I'm not eating any of this
[ __ ] okay you understand I was [ __ ]
my brains out this morning it's not
happening well okay this eat it Olivia
swallow it
it's just an olive dude don't you dare
don't you like olives
don't you like olives Olivia
what it's just an olive how could it be
something right Leo it's just a
knowledge it's just an Olive Garden
it's just an olive
can we find out what's in there now well
you done your last video yeah okay so
yeah finally I'm really curious what
what's going on here Sam
that is sweet potato casserole with
sweet potatoes chopped olives Gorgonzola
cheese and marshmallows okay that's
I don't know I mean it's the blue cheese
with olive no one likes sweet potato
Lena liked it all those things are so
fine on their own but it's the
combination that doesn't sound like the
worst thing ever I feel like can you try
it no no no no I'm not doing it I'm not
interested
um well I'm not laughing okay but I'm
just saying it sounds like something
your weird aunt would bring over for
Thanksgiving Olivia on the document
you're up next
let's do it let's do it for Olivia's
Revenge all right so
um very good very good the scores I
believe it is um one let's recap the
scores then me and Olivia are at four
now yeah and Ila's at three three three
okay and zero zero zero okay I think you
need to eat something I had diarrhea
this morning maybe so you got to respect
my uh uh my abstinence my PC broke
yesterday and I'm still feeling pretty
sad about this so maybe try putting some
it's just the cooler it's easy fix yeah
come on it's a cooler forget about it
all right what do we got up now all
right Olivia's up next how many you have
five videos I do you feeling confident I
have six if we're that's fine whatever
you got and are you feeling confident I
am of course oh you made your own video
I have two original videos
um I'm not going to start with an
original okay
first oh yeah oh so true all right here
we go oh it's the it's the uh potion
once again
sauce that looks kind of good neon red
that does not look right it looks sweet
glowing it looks like slime that
Theodore plays with I'm gonna take a
smell of it it's so red what is this are
you like a witch
whoa
whoa what the [ __ ] there's like bro that
ain't smell right at all
when you eat this one you need a
spoonful oh no I feel like my nose knows
who knows what that is okay ready it's
so red like that how did you even
achieve that color it's glowing like
genuinely I've never seen a food that
color before you have to wait and see
did you did you grind up crayons and put
it in there okay are we ready for my
first yep
let's lock that up
thank you Sam such a gracious wow thank
you thank you Sam that is odors it is
all right I think if somebody doesn't
laugh the whole time there should be a
punishment oh what for being a negative
let's let's cross that bridge when we
get there all right all right listen I
usually take like the fattest L's on
these shows yeah yeah and I talk mad
[ __ ] so if I can get through this yeah I
mean I've only dubbed you uh you you're
the only one I've dubbed because I went
first right let's see here we go let's
start off easy all right in this is one
phase one
in the beginning
in the
in the beginning
foreign
[Laughter]
so that was one two three from what I
could tell you survived yes okay uh what
What's the context of that you know I
really don't know I just know I never
saw my favorites oh yeah he was just
having trouble
having a stroke or something hit the
next words he messes up as well well my
question is because he's speaking the
words in the beginning does that mean he
just opened the Bible and that was the
beginning
right out of the gate he was like
I love it I'm not happy about it so yeah
now I'm in favor of punishing people who
don't laugh sure okay the texture of
this one oh oh my God pudding that's
disgusting the color is [ __ ] up yeah
why is it like opaque can you take it oh
my God plus above this gooin it's
disgusting Sam what the [ __ ] why you had
to put the gross [ __ ] when I have to eat
peanut butter yeah you go firstly and
you're you're the food Warrior
really yeah you go first please I'm just
gonna do it even edible
it's like peanut butter
peanut butter that's what I smelled when
I smelled it okay but that's not that's
what's that's not bad okay okay now she
changed your mind don't believe her she
ate the story that means nothing you two
are ruining the show you know you're
ruining the food and you're ruining the
lab I'm sorry just look at her I think
it just I'm just so nervous and then I
put it and then there's a cup of peanut
butter but you want to go or me yeah do
the whole thing
yeah I'm eating this one yeah can I just
show something like this thing literally
defies gravity anymore like what what is
this this is [ __ ] look at that
okay
same time oh same time I go for it okay
get out of my mouth
[Laughter]
why is it so gooey I hate that it sticks
it stays
it's like putting with um yeah me too
all right wait something that shouldn't
be there yeah interesting it's just not
right it's like the flavors
[Music]
whatever let's just go
I need water I need water this get I
can't watch it though Gamers if I drink
game or something now I will never be
able to drink it again I'll associate it
with these flavors
I hate that why is it
Gabe curse
yo that's what you get for not going to
Gabe's birthday party
water though it's like all over my pants
clean that mess up all right so
that was super fun next up we have do we
want one of my originals or do we want
yeah all right dealer's Choice someone
got me man I'm not happy about it I
don't want to eat any more of that
witch's potion in the beginning okay so
for context this is me in Middle School
eighth grade oh in front of the entire
school I played Ariel in The Little
Mermaid okay this was the final moment
that Ariel sings before she loses her
voice so I was almost done you did Ariel
the whole show I did oh ah it's a big
role singing and everything singing and
everything
all right well this is my most
embarrassing moment ever okay did you
say under the sea no that's that's
Sebastian but did you have any backup on
that I like dancing
is that racist because she's Jamaican it
depends on I guess who plays the role
was a starfish in the movie crab he's a
crap
yeah remember Jamaican Vibes on a crab I
mean
I mean let's talk about it how are we
feeling about that I think the original
guy was Jamaican wasn't he
that'd be [ __ ] crazy if he wasn't
okay
here we go here we go in front of the
whole school my crushes were all sitting
in the audience okay
[Music]
it's turned off okay hold up
how do I get it back
um you moved to the right there we go
there we go it's like opposite
okay here we go so this is little Olivia
yes rewind Olivia yeah I think he needs
the run-up yeah I agree agree here we go
all right we're good
[Music]
whoa that's a great moment thank you and
you ran off because your voice cracked
yes I did I was in the next you're like
oh my God I gotta go that's good that's
very good that's epic I can't believe
you shared that with us yeah straight
from a sitcom yeah it's it was my worst
moment I already put it in the behind
the scenes that's why oh so you're
familiar okay but that's good that's a
good clip man yeah wow yeah that's
powerful yeah that's powerful that's
very good thank you okay next up we have
this one
yeah afraid oh you're so sweet
oh afraid
[Music]
oh baby
just wait
dude that's so funny
that's so [ __ ] good
dude I'm sorry but as a parent that [ __ ]
cracked me the [ __ ] up like you don't
give a [ __ ] bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
God [ __ ] dude stop it then get serious
this is what always [ __ ] up dude like I
get so serious everyone goes oh you're
never gonna laugh and then
it's all right
look at this though like genuinely what
is this made of that's not that's not
like normal matter that's like what's
weird sort of super witchcraft batter
it's in a super state
[ __ ] you
whatever just stop all right can you get
some more water please yeah
okay let me just take the lid off yeah
okay
all right I'm not laughing anymore yeah
right I have one that I know will get
you it's not kidding me okay all right
here we are
yo why is there so much floaters in this
bro what the [ __ ] do you put in here
you see that
there's a lot of floaters it's like
harder just straight particles but
that's from the water cooler it's a
Brita so are you serious that does not
look right in the cup because this looks
clear yeah look at this oh yeah what was
in the cup before
grape juice this grape juice yeah it's
probably from The Grapes okay okay I can
live with that but cheese is so gnarly
in there
if you want a clean cup it's minerals
he said you want you want the sediments
in there not to know all right parts per
million not parts for 10. this is a
compilation of all of the fails in a
community performance of Peter Pan
it's just like your video this was all
once this is all one show foreign
yes
I'm not
I'm not doing this
I'm in this stage and I'm scared for
these kids
play it off no oh my God I'm like
no [ __ ] way
God damn it
laughs
[Music]
dude it's not fair you got kids dangling
from
wow I mean swung around like rag dolls
Oh that was maybe the toughest one yet I
survived so who all got what he tries
[Laughter]
thank god dude you're a Red Goose no
problem Ragu do I double dip I wasn't
trying to write you out but if I don't
say anything the audience will okay you
ratted her out bro it did yeah he did
wow
okay it gets worse right it's just no I
just swallowed it right away I didn't
want to yeah you want to deal with that
favorite yeah to me it was like a coach
it coached my mouth yeah it stays there
yeah it linkers this round because I
really don't want to do this one thanks
should I do so I have two more I can
just do one more though because one's
bonus just just blast them blast them
all right do it yeah
Under the Sea can I sing Under the Sea
and with the Jamaican accent or is that
right I mean nothing is going to stop
you is the things well uh here's the uh
original Sebastian voice actor Samuel e
Wright okay I do not know if he is
Jamaican though uh he is
of African descent however so we love
that for him is he crap don't we damn I
don't
see anything in his bio about any crab
genealogy but well he's from South
Carolina so I'm gonna say no on the uh
Jamaican thing okay okay here we go okay
all righty and D Club meets every
Tuesday during Flex
have room to stop interrupture
learn more about DND Club please visit
edenpr.org
driver's ed fall and winter classes are
now open for registrations ephs is
pairing up
someone laughing behind the camera or
something but no no it's part of the
video but it's like someone going like I
think it's her friend laughing okay okay
contact
to learn more
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
this next one is Maya Ridge okay I'm
great exciting
why are you laughing
you better take a bite of this potion
girl here we go
[Music]
you edited this I did
what's the music from
[Music]
whoa oh [ __ ]
[Music]
whoa that's it
you almost got a few people you almost
got me wait play it again because I
actually missed I looked away and then I
missed it yes
I saw something happen I saw Jay Leno on
the his incubator thank you
for a commercial MP4 well named uh yeah
so I was familiar with the this little
jump scare video
oh so that's a very famous video from
when I was a kid that we would show each
other scary car commercials oh really
remember that yeah that monster thing it
would always scare your friends really I
had I had I had an I had like a vision
of Jay in his hyperbaric chamber and
then after you went yeah after you went
you were like I would never put him in
the hyperbaric chamber I I kept it
classy it was the car crash but that
would have been too much but I think the
image is good well okay good I like my
actuality it's funny because I
immediately was like this is gonna be a
Jay Leno jump scare but I was wondering
if you were gonna do what uh that video
to tie in with the car commercial like
it's just right
that also would have been good yeah all
right
okay
all right Lena what's the score at Ian
figure
uh it is Ethan with two Lena with four a
b with zero ELO with five Dan with four
and Olivia with four so you're in the
first place
and did we find out what was in this oh
yeah Sam oh yeah fill us in that is
cranberry sauce with pickle juice
strawberry glaze peanut butter sweet
tart ropes
the year with the pickle juice I feel
like you've done that before it's such a
weird little twist yeah
yeah I mean it's not it's not not good
with strawberry strawberry
the color and textures yeah it's crazy
okay
all right up now is Lena how are you
feeling you feeling confident I I feel
confident about my first few videos yes
and then it gets worse as you go on uh
well Sam helped me out a little bit
because I could I only found three and
then so he'll help me out with
yeah that's nice okay well before we get
started Sam introduced us to the next
dish if you would please
Alfredo's ready to take a bite nice
traditionally these are just dinner
rolls can't help but notice there's some
sort of black ooze on the side there's
straight up yeah here yeah there's
straight up feces in the middle of this
oh my God
a little bit of an accident
okay all right all right I'm not
laughing me neither I don't want to find
out what's in there dude I'm doing the
worst I gotta stop yeah you gotta get
together do I need to raise the volume
here or uh yeah go ahead and turn it up
all the way okay all right here we go
Lena's first video
from ring
mm-hmm
oh not a grandma
be right back okay stay there oh no bro
don't tell me you didn't lock the
wheelchair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you [ __ ] up dude oh my God oh my God
dude what a idiot
that was a good one I've never seen that
somehow
about poor woman dude Nana took a ride
Nana was so scared Nana took the ride of
her life
so if that didn't get you I think this
one might
oh what and okay
wait what did that say oh I said this
video might be inappropriate to some
users but it passed on YouTube like oh
oh did someone die in it no well let me
show you this why don't we just watch
watch is that okay we're not live so
we're just watching if it's cool it's
cool if we need a sensor it we can yeah
exactly it's just like a claymation yeah
I can't imagine not getting any
restricted
what I've never seen this man this is
weird [ __ ] hi stranger okay
it's been a while
I've missed you
it's okay you can look at my butt
I feel like I can really be vulnerable
around you
you love this video you know do you like
this tree I made
it's making me feel comfortable
oh that was cool
I love that Lena loves this it's so hard
to make things sometimes you know
it just takes so much mental energy and
I get so tired
[Music]
wow
check out the sunset
so nice to stop and take all this in
makes you enjoy being alive
[Music]
even you
I love looking at you
I would remember all your shapes
thank you
[Music]
beautiful
oh he didn't I've been thinking about
you a lot lately
I see you trying to do so many things at
once worrying about a decision you made
or worried that you said the wrong thing
to someone
you're so hard on yourself
you're wonderful
and worthy of being loved
you really are
you just have to let yourself believe it
[Music]
well I know you're really busy and you
probably have to go
but I'm glad I got to see you for a
minute
I love you
[Music]
wow you guys that's impressive we're
loving that the sweetest thing I've ever
seen
wait why was that age restriction
that is a dumb it's a [ __ ] claymation
butt are you crazy I think we can get
away with it weird one what's wrong with
that dude I don't know
um where'd you find that
um I don't know actually
yeah I enjoyed that a claymation butt
I'm just tripped out
oh
I love him it's your boy I found out
about him oh for real he's he's become
like one of the most famous internet
personalities my favorite is the video
of him going
oh I know he looks like a grown-up it's
crazy
he actually is he is a girl he's an
adult
yes I do not know he has what's going on
wait what yeah he's an adult he has some
disease that causes him I'm gonna cut
this no really no I think a lot of
people probably he's a teen he's in his
20s I did not know that yeah oh my God
does that change your perspective of him
I mean my idea of who he was is
different because now he's older let me
let me sorry I thought he was a kid yeah
Hezbollah age it's like 22 or something
yeah something he's 20. crime of his
life
bro yeah yo his bowl is ready to say
he's ready to fight a [ __ ]
he can it's true it's true 20.
perfectly legal I've never seen him so I
don't know you don't know what this is
Yo Amy his Bella could [ __ ] right now
yes he can wait oh that dude eating
probably does frankly he's actually very
devout I know that I am Muslim yeah he's
he's real serious about it
yeah
random video from eating I know it's
strong and he looks like a bird
wow what a what a character okay one
more time actually that was really short
what's he eating I wonder my favorite
video in the world
sorry this curse arm is trying to get it
okay so good so interesting did anyone
laugh I think I giggled accidentally
accidentally huh because I forgot we
were playing a game what are we eating
Hezbollah
he eats skittish like an animal
he's like a squirrel or something like
that's just me and me and me and we got
Olivia with that one all right now I
want to know what's in that goddamn roll
dude let's go so Lena or Olivia's cut it
in half there's some kind I told you
this straight up duties in there bro oh
my gosh what color is that it's like
dark green that's a new color I've never
seen this what does it smell like what
does it smell like name it
[Music]
let's let's see the cross section that
is mayonnaise based oh [ __ ] oh gross
it's not
let's see the cross section I want to
see what we're dealing with here
earliest thing I've ever seen yummy that
roll looks nice I mean nice and soft
well cooked ew dude there's so much of
it
it looks like baby [ __ ] like I mean just
[Music]
yeah get a close-up of that color I mean
that looks like a soiled diaper yeah 100
that is right on soiled diaper
yummy okay well Bon Appetit yeah hope is
below was worth it enjoy already
I feel nauseous oh my gosh
that yeah that's uh I'm like preparing
because I'm like you got this I said
just got this done it fast
oh
okay yeah let's hunt first go ahead come
on you're gonna spit you have to spit
out everything you've eaten but she's
struggling
can we get some chews in there yeah okay
she's chewing she's shaking quivering
probs
what are you experiencing at the moment
she's not doing well I'm just getting
I'm like focused centering again yeah
yeah Center yourself taking a test
okay Olivia's doing good it looks like
she's gonna get it down good job I got
the sauce good good good good good good
the sauce well done well done talk us
through that what kind of flavors were
you experiencing okay
foreign
there's like some like maybe not
gingerbread or some flavor that I know
at Christmas time
maybe peppermint
peppermint why does it look like duties
um
maybe there's like a little bit of
chocolate or something of the sort and
then something that offsets that and
then the bread sounds disgusting
interesting Sam seems impressed maybe
soy sauce
no but you're that's a good uh
observation thank you interesting okay
okay
okay all right let's power on I mean
what we got
Lena has two more rightly yeah
these are the ones
Sam donated to them so these are these
are Sam oh yeah contributions
see the security guard's reaction
s
you know what I'm saying
she's just all the way beautiful I need
you to stand right here for me and look
in the mirror
now walk your knees all the way back
and watch your ass all the way up
see I got a big long tongue you heard me
I just want to kiss you on your booty
[Applause]
and I like to swipe the credit card for
y'all that don't know what's life in the
credit card I just I got a big long ass
turn out you want to go up and down and
crack your ass bro what are you doing
this guy a musician who is he
[Applause]
then I just want to just grab all your
[ __ ] in my mouth and just open that
[ __ ] up with me
[Music]
oh my god dude yo what is happening
foreign
[Music]
dude the security guy almost got me
because it pans over to him and he's
like hell no that's Kevin Gates at a
concert
so graphic
I want to [ __ ] lick your [ __ ]
clean girl
why I I don't know if I saw it
incorrectly but I feel like I saw ELO
laugh oh really well Olivia definitely I
giggled at something that Dan said if
you guys want me to take another bite
yeah what he was and I said he's a
preacher do you dispute Ela
ah
I really tried not to because looking at
this thing yeah it's terrific I think
Olivia's
it may not be as bad as it looks but
yeah I think I mean I think he is right
I did oh okay all right
he's got you got eagle eyes too little
yeah
don't miss nothing dude that looks so
foul like if that thing tastes like
pumpkin pie I don't if it looks like
that it's you can't eat it if you ask me
to eat that or the sweet potato I would
choose that all right
crazy yeah
well you loved the sweet potato I didn't
love it you did you loved it I remember
you loving it I remember you loving it
yeah you eat with your
find that inside of a diaper
I'm just being real say that just take a
fork and eat out the diaper stop stop
yummy yes here we go it looks like when
he's when like Bruce started eating food
for the first time
a little
go for it go ahead
nice bike that was a good bite
oh
she's got it
you got it good job the paper peppermint
I think oh not the peppermint again
are you feeling Bruce's [ __ ] at all or
is that what about Christmas do you
taste Christmas I do it's so funny and
like I don't even know Christmas food
but I guess but that's it it makes sense
it's got to be the peppermint yeah
something like that that was disgusting
but yeah you did good job
all right okay
that's the peppermint that's the curse
dude
that's the one that got us all so bad
last year
oh
I thought you were gonna take it out
well it was just
it walked away
who is that
that was good that was Good Sam that was
good that was good I knew what was
coming and I still was hard
that was good okay that was my stuff
beautiful all right good job thank you
guys thank you I'm so glad I survived it
you really didn't want that one I'm next
okay she's ready come here there's only
like one more round to get him oh my
goodness
twice Olivia look what you did you
jerked ready come here all right A B is
up the impenetrable the humorless maybe
we do need to uh have Sam reveal the
last dip yeah yes so that was dinner
rolls with maple syrup Ranch and mint
Oreos
that's gnarly [ __ ] devilish Branch
mint Oreos and what Maple and maple
syrup that's evil wait so there's no
Peppermint there's the mints
yellow that's different that was
disgusting dude the color was so wild
all right round the next round this
one's for a b all right you guys we're
bringing out the next dish ooh a pie
yummy but it looks like a pumpkin pie
looks nice it's textured
yeah that texture don't look right it's
supposed to be smooth definitely it's
not like that can I smell like gravel
you know let's just get into it because
we're running short on time so a b if
you would please do the honors what
maybe the computer
[Music]
oh
foreign
it's on the game animal Slaughter
Ed
call him a comma comma
comma Comma Chameleon there's one
sorry wow all right that was good that
almost got me yeah that really almost
got me what the hell what was that holy
[ __ ] uh I don't know some dude laughing
weird but if that didn't get you uh
here's a show where they brought
together a bunch of people with unique
laughs whoa
lost it I like how they're all laughing
at like the person next to them they're
like this lady got a dumb one
doing that
whoa
oh my God
it's a pack of hyenas
oh my God Papa part until I die
oh my God
[Music]
no shot
this is real
okay
um
it's just the chorus how they get each
other going sounds like the same people
on typhoon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I've seen that video before that's the
only reason that oh yeah I was very
close but I was like how do you get all
these people with like their animal
they're like yo we found a pig lady a
rooster later a monkey lady
so was that Lena and Elena got it I
didn't I didn't hear it I don't know you
were hiding your face but I'll leave it
up to Ian I'm not gonna put that on you
I wouldn't do that uh since we got you
on the last round we'll let it slide
dude that looks so happy Star Wars day I
was trying not to breathe as a technique
yeah yeah
to feel pressure like okay oh you were
gonna faint you're like I'd rather faint
and eat this [ __ ] because I don't have
like a you know what maybe give me a
look yeah scary um yeah maybe a spoon
yeah I think it's probably easier yeah
is that beans it's just refried beans oh
my God it's beans it's refried beans I
think you might be right but I don't
know what the [ __ ] else is in there yeah
interesting so wait is it just Lena yeah
oh sorry oh
so is it the crust or is there something
floating in there
okay so we got we gotta fish it out we
don't know Lena has so far been unfazed
so no I don't know I smell the beans
just one this one's tough okay you don't
like beans not really you don't like
Mexican food I do but beans not so much
not especially not like a bean pie a
bean pie well sure I don't think many
people are cut up for that yeah what is
happening
I I have a guess where it smells so it's
fish isn't it no no no the fish dish is
the one that'll be for me you gotta you
gotta dig Sam maybe you should serve her
yeah I can't really tell what I'm
looking for I just know it smells dude
there's a full on archaeological search
going on there yeah
some fossils all right
really hurt oh so it melted in there
it's in there so just take a take a
little nibble it smells like something
that's not a food item yeah are you
right it is that you're it is edible
right Sam okay
my microplastic
okay I'm just gonna do it do it sound it
once again unfazed Lena is just munching
away
oh no this is the little face this one
she's having trouble oh no okay oh fine
yeah yeah okay
if that's Lena's reaction you know
that's just a huge wow is that meat is
there no meat she said there's no
meaning it's not meat
oh my God are you okay
talk through the flavors
I can't even describe it it's like dude
get a shot of that uh damn now that it's
been cracked into yeah that's why I
can't get put my hand on it's like that
meat pie but frankly Jason can you smell
it just smell it at the same time I
could see Taco Bell serving this on
Thanksgiving
I know one of
them I'm not smelling it
get a little closer it smells like dog
food oh God okay that's not a dog food
it's not dog food everything is human
food
[Music]
okay so this one is short uh Elena
suffering you may have seen it yeah you
may have seen already but I know not not
to this degree okay okay I guarantee oh
these two oh no this guy birthday and
because it's my birthday I get to
introduce you to my girlfriend who is
amazing this is the worst day everyone
today yeah I've seen this Thursday
everyone today is also my birthday and
because it's my birthday today everyone
today is also my birthday and because
it's Monday everyone today is also my
birthday and because it's my birthday I
get to introduce you to my girlfriend
birthday Marcus you don't want to do
this let her go breaking news a man is
currently holding his girlfriend hostage
police are outside of his home waiting
negotiation terms breaking news
following his girlfriend hostage police
are outside team news a man is currently
holding his girlfriend hostage police
are awesome
I know we are all aware of the current
market situation developing I want to
assure you I have my my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my birthday otherwise I wouldn't
get to tell you about her she doesn't
allow me anything on my when it's not I
don't know and she's like sitting on his
lap he does news I I might have missed
does anyone want to come did anyone else
laugh anyone want to come clean oh you
think you saw something okay I did
this time
again round two anyone else coming clean
just me and you oh I meant it I was very
good I was very close and then I got it
all right so I'm just gonna go in for
for a nibble yeah right that's all and
this is it this is all I'm doing I mean
that's too much yeah no that's fine I'm
here yeah that's what I did and it was
enough unless you want to just take food
I have it here he's got it
Bottoms Up I don't know here we go I
don't want to do it and here we go and
here we go and taking a bite I don't
want to do it running low on time we
gotta keep this moving we still got them
here comes the airplane
[Music]
I can't do it
you got it just beans you love beans why
is it so chewy Sam
why is it so [ __ ] chewy it's not
beans
or is it a meat supplement is
this the shredded the liver uh king
penis thing what no no that's me
nice that's so [ __ ] gross dude why is
it so chewy it's like for sure meat or
fish but you're saying it's not I hate
no meat no meat in there okay I won't go
down it won't go down what is this you
have to swallow it whole
yep okay I got a little shooter
you got the disgusting [ __ ] freak
food you go now here we go oh my God and
swallow it's the chewiness it's so far I
don't want to do it just take just hit
it with water you know what I mean wash
it down oh
no are you okay
oh wow she hit that gamer so hard yeah
that was so bad I don't recommend no
that's gross that's so gross it's so
gross
all right that's the worst one yeah all
right EB keep it rolling [ __ ] I
thought that's almost the worst but vile
dog [ __ ] [ __ ]
evil Amanda
oh gentlemen this is manifest
the headlock here
[Applause]
this is the bike who got me on the penis
people oh what is the charge eating a
meal a succulent Chinese meal
are you waiting to receive my limp penis
look I'm under water
so many times but it's so good who the
[ __ ] is this guy give him a show dude
they had a little war around him I
remember when this went viral many years
ago
the backstory is why arrest him for
eating a succulent Chinese meal this is
one of the ones that I just put in the
dock because mother got claimed so well
it's a good one
I'm not laughing again on this I don't
give a [ __ ] what you do you ready for
the last one I'm out no there's no cut
there's no humor left in my life
three minutes
[Laughter]
see some people breaking there's nothing
funny about life
there's literally no humor left
[Laughter]
don't tell me he's watching Family Guy
he's watching Family Guy what the [ __ ]
is that what they do on Twitch running
around like look at my baby dick
what
[Laughter]
mental illness
it's infectious
yeah
I'm like Dixon's side of my ass smile
[Laughter]
you can laugh at your video and
how you doing Dan is this a cooking time
you see me I'm [ __ ] dead bro there's
no comedy in the world me too I'm
looking I'll look at anything no I'm
dead
there's not even audio
did you meet it that's how my whole life
sounds
just silent
he has a really good Noise Gate
I don't believe you
[Laughter]
it's so awesome
[Music]
I think you were gay
80 million votes
Hassan is a racist proven
[Laughter]
it's the most consistent laughing it is
very consistent I thought we would get
like 20 seconds into that and I stop it
but then I kind of just was funny I see
you yeah but but there's nothing really
good but I'm not eating that yeah I'm
not eating that [ __ ] bro there's
something about other people laughing oh
that was my strategy I had five videos
of other people laughing yeah
no the two of them the guy claimed had
it replaced that's a shame
is that all is that it that's it all
right maybe good job so uh thank you AV
for presenting Sam where we got him yeah
hold on that is pumpkin pie with pumpkin
Mayo impossible meat and then that's
what it was remember when I said is it a
mental institute
I had a feeling it might yeah it must
have been impossible me but that was so
Mentos
yeah I said something peppermint I sent
peppermint dude that's the weird texture
of the impossible meat and that was so
[ __ ] gross because you had to really
chew it yeah all right I'm gonna do some
chairs here okay uh Lena laughed on that
one but I feel like she's eaten enough
of this stuff so oh I think I'll just oh
my gosh I'll give a point but I will
miss Grace
then I was
[Laughter]
like I had to do that twice no yeah I
mean okay so here we are the final round
Dan is going to try to make us laugh Sam
if you could bring out the dish and then
after this we have a bonus
one for the big losers is that right
salmon that is right here we go yummy we
have what is the string beans
traditional string beans
green bean casserole yes here let me uh
pop this open real quick actually no
that thing is not right
I mean on the top you got like a thing
right is there bacon in this no no
[Laughter]
uh final uh scorecard recap Ethan with
three yeah uh Lena was seven uh oh ELO
was six
okay Olivia with five and a b with zero
[ __ ] Lane maybe should have to take a
bite of that last one I'm dead inside
hmm interesting really you just sipping
champagne bro cruising
here we go go go go not laughing
DJ Khaled bring it I don't give a [ __ ]
bro
power washer
some boy have stone and my life we have
Limestone ain't believing us
God did
on a horse
he's right man
make sure you take care of what you love
you know life is like a flower
you have to take care of it give it
water Let It Shine if you don't take
care of it
god dude
you know what I love he went out there
with no plan he just said record
just this last second where he just like
totally loses his trance yeah yeah yeah
give it water
what happens
Believe in Us god dude oh my god
did and he built out from there was that
me laughing at the video yeah it was of
course it was but you left and in real
life what happened yes
yeah you know
um it's like the third time I've done
that I can't tell if kel is an idiot or
a genius he's like that video tells me
ladies yeah I mean look he he he has
some clearly he has some
some kind of talent but he's not very
bright he does that all on purpose or
he's just well you told me what do you
think I think he's shaking he's
definitely dude god dude over his
Snapchat he's doing shtick I mean I've
already had a Snapchat of him being
stuck in the middle of the ocean on a
jet ski I have watched that was so fun
like two dozen times in the last week
all right so uh Olivia's going in for
the first bite
with some kind of sauce and God help us
there she is Olivia's end for the bite
good job Olivia it's all in the mouth
she's chewing
she's soldiering up
good good right
um
it's all over your lips all over your
teeth oh my God you can get it you got
it you're a soldier
kick it back
there you go wash it down with some
Gamers up with code Nations
H3 did it all right
that was good man that was impressive
good job and and so what did you uh what
did what were you picking up on in there
uh like fish and green beans sounds
about right yeah and like cream I don't
think I can do that like genuinely on
the face I can't do that well don't
laugh them what do you look like I just
do I look like I'm in a laughing mode
oh boy it's really good oh boy ping news
I have in her big news oh boy CNN is
more so Donald Trump oh boy oh man
here's a video of it so Donald's big
news Donald Trump big news big news
Donald Trump oh boy the d.o.p news oh
boy so Donald Trump oh boy so Donald
Trump oh boy okay you know what made me
laugh even more is that I realized he's
like a Twitter reply guy when I saw his
Avatar he was also
um a character on the reality show the
YouTube reality show uh summer break
when he was in high school yeah okay
holy smoke oh boy that almost got me
almost got me I think if I hadn't seen
it before I would have been [ __ ] yeah
because I always see his avatar on
Twitter when I was on Twitter
and he's like one of these reply guys
he's always like dunking on
conservatives right and apparently he's
a whole boy oh boy
here's another one that you've seen
before
golf cart bro
you're laughing bro your mouth was
opening yeah Mom's closed but
that's one being and one God brother
[Music]
damn
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
let's put the guitar up that's a good
question it's rap
imitation check it out kids
these [ __ ] been wanting this rough for
years
you want some of this him and his kid
his kid and him
and even horny the owl that wanted to
straw let me tell you son you want this
raw yeah come get it
wow forget about it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
it's been a while since I've seen it raw
I know it's all good and this is this is
the regular volume one this is the one
that started it all it was my dog has
never quivered in my life I was
quivering oh God that was really good I
love the raw yes I do not that it was
our boy Bradbury yep that's him
that's him all right and regular the raw
the regular Raw
that last one a little bit but I held it
together all right
all right uh this is definitely a switch
up from the type of content we love it
oh my gosh we love it
so cute is this dog gonna try to eat the
pig or something maybe it's so cute what
the [ __ ]
something's about to go wrong I'm
preparing myself
[Music]
in that thing
some fish casserole Play it Again Play
it again at least so I can enjoy it
this video is so cute though actually I
know that pigs can be so funny
and technically you're right it is the
second place
oh that's not fair poor Lena Lena will
have tried everything oh no I was
laughing at the title yeah yeah did you
know the picture
videos
Ian you decide maybe maybe the gods can
can Grace her with uh Ian uh you haven't
tried this one yet no yeah well maybe a
little bite but Lena currently has the
most points so I don't want to give her
more points yeah yeah I feel that I feel
that's not right what is this oh shut up
believes in the rules I'll do it for you
Dan
when I got angry at Dan I may have
cursed too many times you know what I
mean they got that word bro you might
have to remove a couple of those [ __ ]
yeah or just drop the audio
okay okay or bleep them yeah that would
be good yeah bleep them all right dude
this looks so gross Sam what the [ __ ]
bro there's definitely like mayonnaise
and chocolate and whatever [ __ ] nasty
ew stop
[Music]
are you eating this oh you're not yeah
you know how don't do it to yourself
[Laughter]
I took too big of a piece mom you cut it
in half I can't like chug this [ __ ] like
you guys who like deep just like monster
this thing down
all right cheers
oh the smell yeah it's we love green
beans I do love green beans not anymore
after today
what do you think
you know what the [ __ ] yo no it's the
fish
I'm just remembered as fish in it
I say I can't swallow it I hate this
[ __ ] take it like a pill obstacles
there you go that was Primal that was
Primal as [ __ ] you're not so Primal ew
[ __ ]
all right uh wait who tried did someone
already try this oh yeah Olivia yeah
right yep ew something like so burned in
there Sam huh
all right it's not laughing anymore this
is uh one of my favorite guys on Tick
Tock unfortunately most of his videos
were getting claimed
I did manage damn it to find one
that didn't though a shout out to my boy
did the green beans put you in a bad
mood bro I've been in a bad mood since
the damn pudding but whatever the bumper
are you ready everybody really bad here
we go
and my team is the best for me welcome
to Argentina
got me this dude is claiming these I
find that great
I think it's probably the music that he
uses in most of his videos get claimed
or something yeah yeah he didn't claim
it but was he he's just saying welcome
to Argentina yeah he's not in Argentina
um oh he's not yeah no apparently he's
in Singapore so um he just likes
Argentina so he's saying welcome to
Argentina he's playing for the Napoleon
Skyline yes or like maybe Argentina's
like last night he's a fan of the
Argentina and uh uh soccer team football
team is uh my inference from his jersey
but yeah there's he has better videos I
don't know if you guys have come across
this guy before he's really [ __ ]
funny but um and you Dan yep I know all
right last one that was good last video
I I can't believe you got me with that
dumb [ __ ] Tractor video again I was
like Dan don't hit me with that Tractor
video again
it's not fair I even said to him when he
sent me the videos I was like Dan I'm
surprised you didn't sneak that Tractor
video in because I didn't I'm the only
idiot the whole pig video
you know I was like wow
God damn it all right you guys ready
this [ __ ] hell no
hell no dude
I love refrigerators no
it's the George it's the game one more
time wow here we go
this is a real this is 100 real
I mean I believe him yeah I do he's sold
wasting a lot of AD time walking up
I love refrigerators it's powerful
I've been having to stop myself from
saying that all day today because it's
been stuck in my head like how the sound
bites get I love refrigerator
bro I wanted to eat dinner tonight
well now you can because uh that's it
that's oh that's all of them that was
the end oh God so um we need to find out
who unfortunately I'm pretty sure we
know go ahead go ahead with the final
Tower yeah what's in this oh good point
this is green bean casserole with green
beans cream of mushroom soup sardines
instant coffee grounds oh my gosh that's
what tasted so burnt the nasty jalapeno
topping oh that is [ __ ] boy that's
dark magic dude yeah
the coffee grounds I was like there's
something really bitter in this all
right well Ian our final tally is uh a b
with zero wow what a champion I think
the winner and loser got to take a bite
and in fact it's the it's the lovely
stuff I'll do it I'll do it for Elena
okay well thank you actually you know
what wait I'll allow that the final one
round
yeah
I'm actually cool with that Lena's been
through a lot too maybe just maybe just
wait until yeah all right bring it out
Bring up the cursed uh final day ab was
Zero Dan with four Ethan with four oh
okay then Eli and Olivia with six each
and then Lena was set yeah I won wait
are those the spicy chips they sure are
you busy
listen those aren't the ones one of
those chips is not like the others
also there what oh yeah in that
guacamole
Jello or something jello
okay so gross looks like an art piece
dude you made a lot of it do you see
this this is kind of like our dude this
is kind of yeah should you Jiggle It for
Dan yeah there you go wait but one of
these this isn't the chip it's not the
spicy chip is it one of them yeah one of
them is that chip are you serious yeah
because I feel but it's because that one
was blue
yeah there's lots I see it I see it what
it's a
no Dan I
well I mean it's obvious
it may not be obvious what's the spicy
what's the spice on it
on the night oh it's just chili powder
it's not that it's not that spicy well
well hold on hold on let me let me look
at this
oh yeah yeah it's where the light hits
now I see it yeah you can see it this is
like a [ __ ] horror
how do you think you're out of hell
anyway I feel like you gotta eat the
spice you want no I live in the hospital
no yeah it's he's gonna bomb or or okay
or orlina does it I mean she can handle
the spicy chips no do you love me oh
well if you're not even the hit the
regular one if you're not one yeah if
you're not eating the spicy chip you're
bailing on this
chili powder is hot but it's not like
insane but the other chips I feel like
has the residue on it
Sam would tell you pick the one farthest
away from it Sam would tell you Sam make
sure you get some jello on there yeah
yeah take a big old bite bro that's too
small
come here and yeah make sure make sure
he's getting something good because this
dude didn't take a single bite of food
so we got to make sure Elena's got your
pup already don't worry hungry though we
didn't you earned it and now you earned
the respect and Adoration of your wife
this is a beautiful Act of Love A
selflessness and love yep
yeah look for search for that please um
I can only imagine yeah there it is what
is that yum yum
what is that oh wait wait stop stop
bring out your phone wait stop what
you're doing who is that what are you
doing trying to get it we just gotta
people gotta see what's happening here
okay go ahead yeah grab that you need a
spoon or something what is the pit
there's some sort of like pit there's
also oh that's covered in Gross beans
holy [ __ ] baby
what the [ __ ] is that don't worry about
it
all right it's kind of big
yeah that's a big [ __ ] bite yo
baby look real worried the whole thing
right Sam
whatever you can do he's got to be
hungry wait
yes my man a b he did it he ate the
whole thing what a guy
what a guy how is it I mean he's working
it down yeah he's going through
something but he's working it down I
don't know is it spicy oh no no it's not
spicy but something
[Music]
happened you want to tell us what it is
Samus he's eating it yeah
oh
[ __ ]
that is
that's avocado lemon lime jelly oh [ __ ]
I can't hear you still keep
me okay all right all right all right
all right go ahead go ahead Sam that is
guacamole with avocado lemon lime Jello
maraschino cherries bean dip and chili
powdered chips but that doesn't sound
that bad what was the big chunky
that was probably the the cherry or the
jello yeah all right thanks for watching
Everybody Happy Thanksgiving oh my God
Thanksgiving everyone Olivia is this
she's just gone Olivia's gone she left
she went home okay
yeah we're gonna have to cut it off here
thanks everybody happy pretty sure he
loves you yeah I think yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure everyone's probably
worked up a good appetite here for
Thanksgiving so let's all go have a nice
meal and uh call it a day huh and
yeah
baby
yeah all right all right thank you guys
uh thanks for watching thank you
everybody thank you yeah and
congratulations yes
thank you sandwich the madness people
like to call Sam the uh
uh she's like uh let's say uh Martha
Stewart who [ __ ] uh went to hell I
remember yeah okay whatever you're about
you're Martha Stewart but like
evil but she went to the house it's not
enough it's not enough evil doesn't
cover it dark Martha dark Martha thank
you oh Amy's running the bathroom okay
all right thank you guys thank you
everybody see ya see ya
foreign